dude the dog you might want to give Ben
some pointers on the proper fur boy
etiquette at auradon
it looks like he needs some help
controlling that temper of his and while
you're at it can you talk to Audrey and
tell her to take things down a notch you
know things are getting pretty wild when
a talking dog is the most reasonable
subject in the kingdom of auradon
Carlos's dog from the Disney's
descendants franchise is a loyal
companion and a hilarious jokester he
even helped the gang outsmart uma and
her crew in d2 but there's much more to
do the dog than that here's the truth
about the auradon prep campus mutt that
stole Carlos's heart don't you guys
think it's weird that dude the dog just
came out of nowhere when Ben was timing
Carlos's run seriously where did that
little guy come from there's a chance it
was set up that way all along then is a
smart and compassionate leader as the
prince of auradon after all it was his
idea to bring some of the villain kids
off the isle and onto the royal soil he
must have known how difficult that
transition would be for Carlos and his
friends when Ben introduces Carlos to
dude he seems to be pretty familiar with
him already it's almost as if Ben set up
this little encounter for Carlos so he
could have an emotional support animal
to get him through the transition to his
new life
[Music]
we can just picture it then sees that
Carlos is to this strange new place so
he tells Carlos to meet him in the field
to run some drills little does Carlos
know that been arranged for a dude the
dog to meet them in the field you can
tell that dude is super excited to meet
his new friend a little too excited even
Carlos runs away in fear because of
everything his mom told him about dogs
she called them vicious rabid pack
animals in fact
Pirela de Vil instilled a deep
irrational fear of all canine creatures
into her son's brain even the once as
cute and harmless as dude so it's no
wonder
Carlos headed for the forest and up the
nearest tree to get away from the furry
little guy then picks up the dog and
tries to coax Carlos down from the tree
and then something very telling happens
then introduces dude and Carlos as if
that was his plan all along then wanted
Carlos to get over his phobia of dogs so
that he could make a new friend Carlos
has no choice but to confront his false
beliefs about dude he realizes that dude
doesn't look like a vicious rabid pack
animal did you guys see the smile on
Carlos's face when Ben put dude in his
arms It was as if their friendship was
meant to be when you think about it dude
really changed Carlos's life for the
better but we'll get to that in a minute
first there's another truth that is
glaringly obvious about Carlos and dude
have you ever noticed that people tend
to look and act like their pets this is
definitely the case between Carlos and
dude Carlos has a lot of the same
characteristics as his pooch he's loyal
cute sweet and hilarious though we
didn't know about the last one until
dudes started talking in descendants two
student Carlos both love sweets remember
in the limo when the villain kids were
leaving the Isle of the lost in the
first movie Carlos kept shoving
chocolate in his mouth later indeed -
dude stole the truth gummy right out of
mouse hand these two are a lot alike
also in descendants - Carlos and dude
have almost the same hairstyle it's no
wonder they hit it off right from the
start okay
remember when we said we would get to
the part where dude changed Carlos's
life for the better here's what we mean
by that before dude came along Carlos
was a total scaredy-cat he was even
afraid of the statue that transformed
King Adam into his beast form in front
of word on press as soon as dude was
able to speak he told Carlos to take
charge and ask gene out already
he helped Carlos get over his fear of
dogs he was even the reason that Carlos
was finally able to stand up to his mom
granted it was over a video conference
while he stayed safely in Oregon and
Carla was still trapped on the aisle but
still he told her to give it a rest
that's huge you guys
dude the dog is responsible for Carlos
finally asking Jane to the cotillion
if dude hadn't encouraged him with his
doggie pep talk Carlos might have missed
out on having Jane for a girlfriend if
she does not like you think she is not
the one for you
and we all know how much he adores her
dudes influence has been powerful over
Carlos in a majorly positive way and can
we talk about dudes role in rescuing Ben
and outsmarting uma mal and her crew
would never have been able to pull that
off without dude when they brought the
fake wand for uma they needed to prove
to her that it was real before she
released Ben we all know that wand was a
fake replica made with the 3d printer in
Carlos's room so they needed something
undeniably convincing to trick uma into
believing the wand was real thankfully
dude the dog was there mal pointed to
dude and said talk dog
classic dude Carlos and dude have been
through a lot together we wonder how
this hilarious cat the onion will help
the villain kids in descendant 3 what's
your favorite dude the dog moment from
The Descendants movies tell us in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
if you think dude the dog changed
Carlos's life and be sure to subscribe
to the things for more videos like this
one thanks for watching we'll see you
soon
[Music]